this is a production of cornell
university
okay so what's going to happen if you
weren't here this morning savannah
shellnut is a
graduate student in larry smart's lab
this is her trial it's a powdery mildew
trial
so since it's a trial we ask that you
not take any plant material off of the
plants so she can do her work but i
think if we go inside it uh
we can look at some of the things we're
talking about and i'm going to talk
about bugs today so
let's make our way inside the high
tunnel
okay
welcome inside
the the high tunnel here
real quick in case you weren't here this
morning
a high tunnel is a soil-based greenhouse
and it kind of brings hopefully the best
of both worlds of field production and
that we're using the soil as our
our substrate our growing media
but at the same time versus hydroponic
at the same time we're getting those
greenhouse benefits of
controlling the environment to some
degree
since we are using the soil
and it's a lower technology greenhouse
we are going to probably have
more insect pests than might happen
outside just because we have the soil
here excuse me yeah more than outside
because we also don't have rain
so the ventilation is an important
feature on
i think any greenhouse high tunnels in
particular
we use these roll up sides so that we
have air exchange that air exchange is
critical for any crop grown indoors
it gets more co2 plants use sunlight and
co2 to photosynthesize so that air
replenishment is important for co2
relative humidity
and temperature management as well it
also means that insects can come in and
out through those open sidewalls so
we're clear on that
so
to control those insects
we have to think about what are we going
to do
to do that
i'm going to suggest that we look away
from what we call conventional
pesticides for a few reasons hopefully
that are obvious to all of you one is
the testing that we just heard about in
our previous talk if you're applying a
conventional pesticide to these plants
that might ruin your testing
the next is it's probably illegal so we
don't have what we call traditional
conventional
pesticides that are labeled for cannabis
let alone inside because many of your
pesticides that are registered outside
are not registered inside that means we
need to look at other ways of
controlling these pests
i'm going to talk about
introducing good bugs to control the bad
bugs and we call that
bio control
or yeah bio control there is another way
to do that as well and just as you can
use
what we call microbial fungicides so in
the talk that we just heard from chris's
grad student
where you're spraying either a bacterium
or a fungus onto the plant with the idea
of controlling
the pest disease you can do the same
with insects
using microbials i'm not going to talk
about that i'm going to talk about
releasing the good bugs into control the
bad bugs
so i'm using the word bugs instead of
insects
because we're not just dealing with
insects we're also dealing with mites
you may have heard of mites mites aren't
insects they have eight legs
there's a very common uh pest of
cannabis called two spotted spider mite
we heard about that earlier today too
that's a pest mite the reality is
there's probably more beneficial mites
than there are pest mites so we actually
use good mites and good insects
to control
the bad bugs the bad mites and the bad
insects so i'm going to say bugs as a
general overall term to include both
mites and insects
another reason you might want to look at
introducing good bugs into these high
tunnels or greenhouses
is if you want to do things organic so
if you have a product that you're
representing in some fashion as organic
this is the way to approach that
the other
benefit with introducing
good bugs here is that it's less labor
than spraying anything whether that's an
organic spray or conventional spray
releasing insects is less work i find
than spraying
so
how do we know what to release well the
first thing we have to do is figure out
what we are releasing for what are we
going to introduce a good bug for that
means we're going to scout and to scout
approach one of these beautiful plants
next to you
and start poking around that foliage
you're free to do that savannah it's
okay if they handle the plants is that
correct she says totally
totally
get in there and poke around a little
bit and what i like to do when i'm
looking for
insects and mites i tend to start at the
bottom of the plant particularly in a
high tunnel where we're using soil
and that soil or dust oftentimes is what
gets these insects going so i take a
look at those lower leaves
and i figure out what do i have going on
there i'm not going to go through that
whole exercise
that's generally where i start not all
of your pests will start on the bottom
but it's a very good place to start
looking and if you look at these
cannabis plants you will find some
insects pests low down the canopy
now that i've figured out what
i've got well you haven't figured that
out you figured out you've got something
it's a mite it's an aphid it's a thrips
it's a beetle it's a worm it's something
you need to figure out
is there a beneficial insect or mite
that will control that for me
and so i work with a couple of different
bio control suppliers that are
outstanding sources of information
i have one here from arbico
and one from coppert
and these people are used to working
with the cannabis industry
they have a lot of information on what
are the good bugs that you put in to
control the bad bugs
so a brief word on the good bugs
again we're dealing with beneficial
mites and beneficial insects we divide
those into two major categories they can
either be parasitoids or predators a
parasitoid doesn't eat the bad bug it
somehow disrupts its life cycle so
parasitoid wasps are the common example
of that they lay an egg inside of an
aphid
and then that egg grows and then a wasp
emerges from the aphid it's pretty neat
that's a parasitoid their relationship
with the pest is often highly specific
so they might only lay eggs inside of
one species of aphid or maybe two or
three species of aphids for that reason
i tend to prefer what i call generalist
predators
predators that eat
are bad bugs and they'll eat many of
them so if we look at aphids we not only
have the hemp aphid that that affects
cannabis you also have hop aphids
that'll affect cannabis you have fox
glove aphid you have
potato green potato aphid
lots of them green peach aphid and so i
prefer a generalist predator that eats
all of those it doesn't care what it
eats
and so i'm gonna highlight one of those
here
this is a green lace wing larvae and if
you look at the picture on this bottle
you'll see what that larvae looks like
it looks like a monster
this thing is a monster if you're an
aphid
lace wings are these beautiful green
flying insects in their adult stage with
a very lacy wing
and what they do is they fly around this
high tunnel
they sense where the aphids have their
colonies
and then they lay an egg in the center
of that colony not inside an aphid but
in the middle of that colony that egg
hatches out and then this lace-wing
larvae comes out and it veraciously goes
after any aphid i can find
so i really like this one because it
combines two important assets for me in
bio control one is general predation so
it eats almost any species of aphid eats
many species of aphids and it also has
mobility it flies and it detects where
those hot spots are inside of the
high tunnel so i'll pass this around you
can see that those are commercially
available
you buy that sprinkle it out into your
crop
actually lacewing yeah so laceling
larvae are going to come probably as in
their larva or larval stage
this is a another wasp
the lacewing's not a wasp it's a it's
another flying insect this is a wasp
it's not a parasitoid wasp it's another
generalist
so this is a fidelities and it again
seeks out where are the aphids and it
lays eggs and it goes out and and
consumes those eggs both of these
fantastic generous predators for aphids
for spider mites and thrips we don't
have that flying advantage in that case
our predators have to be shaken out
and they'll come in a
sawdust carrier or vermiculite carrier
just like that
and i would sprinkle that out into my
crop
and they would seek their prey some of
the common ones we would use for mites
would
their names you don't have to memorize
them would be persimilis californicus
for thrips we use a
beneficial mic called cucumerous
again you don't have to learn latin you
don't have to memorize those things talk
with your your bio control provider they
can walk you through that process really
well
now i've got
in front of me
about 3000 square feet savannah is this
30 by 96 maybe
okay so about 3 000 square feet of
growing space
this container has
probably around five hundred or a
thousand
um
of these wasps inside they're gonna
emerge and hopefully find my aphids
a much preferable way to get this
product onto my crop instead of treating
these three thousand square feet
is to treat my transplant area
so these three thousand square feet of
of hemp plants
when they're small or condensed into
maybe 100 square feet on a greenhouse
bench
so i can treat that greenhouse bench
with this
and then once i transplant out into my
high tunnel ideally those plants are
pre-inoculated with the beneficial
so when do we treat we treat early
how often do we treat
that depends on the pest but we're
probably gonna treat often
if you're gonna go this route this this
bio control route
scouting is important but i think it's
more important to release early
you have to commit to this and say i'm
going to go this route and i'm going to
release
if you're growing indoors it's a hot dry
environment you're very likely to have
the pests we mentioned today mites
thrips aphids
assume that you're going to have them
and be prepared and release these early
there's no more words left on my highly
sophisticated notes
questions comments rebuttals
or would you say that this is
you know standard for most high tunnels
uh i would say it's for trials but maybe
savannah savannah's out here i'm right
here yeah you want to address that event
for this trial right i can i'll address
like why we chose this layout a little
bit more in a second yeah will you cover
density
yeah
i don't know much about density but i
would say we're at sub-optimal density
so part of my talk this morning is
focus on this
greenhouse really needs to
produce as much cannabinoid flour as it
can to justify the investment in the
steel and plastic versus growing this in
in the field so for that reason we want
to find what is that optimal density
and i'd say we're well below it at this
point maybe there's a grower in the room
who has an idea on density in square
feet
no is that straight secret go ahead
so can you rotate these biologicals with
low risk pesticides like bt
so the question is can you rotate these
biologicals with low risk pesticides
like bt
so bt for those who don't know is a
naturally occurring it's a toxin that
comes from a bacterium
that specifically targets
a set of worms
and probably has low activity against
many of the species that we're targeting
if you go to the bio control websites
they generally show a compatibility
chart of does this bio control mix well
with
say a bt or another pesticide
my
my approach would be to go with one or
the other on that because in the end you
are applying an insecticide when you're
using a bt and it's probably going to
have some
negative effect particularly on soft
body beneficials that i'm releasing in
here
so knowing that i'm going to control
multiple species i'm going to need
multiple
predators
and i would let them do their
workbox for a while i'd be happy to be
soapboxed but it depends on the topic
steve let's try and keep the commercial
sure hi i'm the rep for marone bio we
sell grand devo and venerate they are
two bio pesticides
the two bio pesticides going to your
question about compatibility um we use
we we've been in the cannabis sector
since the very beginning and we use them
quite a bit for managing uh western
flower thrips all the species of aphids
spider mites broad lights etc
i like them a lot in a bca program and
part of one of your evaluation points is
you're looking at how to integrate all
this mess one of the things i like about
bts although they're specific
caterpillars is the mode of entry into
an insect is by ingestion
most well all of our beneficials are not
eating their plant that's what makes
them beneficial and so you're very
unlikely with a bt or vendival
you actually get any in and then the
mode of action of them is as a stomach
poison so this goes back to if your if
your beneficials are not eating your
plants they're not there's no way
they're going to get any of this product
in here so you can't integrate the two
i find that the whole industry the whole
bca industry cropped up when there were
no bio-pesticides
now we have a whole lot of
bio-pesticides integrating them i think
is the real is the real challenge i'm
talking not just my company bio
pesticides but even though we hate to
admit it there are other bio pesticides
out there
i see a biosafe rep back there
and their products are almost as good as
ours
thank you all very much
yes thank you for those unbiased
comments steve
steve's
room bible science is one of our
sponsors today i encourage you to talk
to steve he's been in the
high tunnel and protected crop and
outdoor crop
world for almost as long as i have been
so a lot of knowledge there
one more quick thought that comes to
mind for me is i look at this high
tunnel and as much as i love soil i
don't always want to see the soil so if
i were this were a commercial production
for me i would mulch this one way or
another either mulch these row middles
with with a plastic film and there are
degradable films you can use today or
with an organic
mulch such as straw or something like
that
that alone is going to
provide a lot of benefits on insect
control it's also going to provide
moisture control it's also going to
provide
weed control and it's also a nicer
working environment for your labor uh
when they're in here doing whatever
they're doing so
quick easy way to control pests or to
reduce your pest load is to mulch these
row mills
heavily
more questions or comments
behind me
do i need a pesticide applicator's
license for bio controls and what about
these bio you know
actual pesticides right so marie ulrich
from orange county asks
do i need a license to apply
either microbial products or beneficial
insects the answer is no you don't
so there's another set of paperwork you
don't have to go through which you don't
have to jump through and again if you
look at that ocm webpage they're really
encouraging you to
be as organic as possible
that said whenever you use a labeled
pesticide as a farmer in new york state
you are required to keep a record of
that how much product did you use and
when did you use it and even the organic
materials do have what we call re-entry
intervals and you have to respect those
and they have ppe requirements in other
words you have to wear certain clothing
or protective equipment
so
detection
and are subject to worker protection
standards
mary loves talking about this stuff
she's the one to go to when you have
questions on
legal things
i'm good for other questions
thoughts comments if not i'm probably at
the end of my time
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu